with all these white kids now walking
around trying to act like they're like
gangster rappers
it's irritating it's like everywhere i
go man i think it'd just be here in the
city we got a good mix of people
you know i'll be like in the middle of
kansas though like the whitest state
ever there'll be some howdy howdy-doody
looking white kid like me you know i'm
thinking this is one of my peeps
somebody can have a conversation with
i'll say she's like yo what's up kid
who saw a kid i just want to be like
nothing much brad
you know you're keeping it real in
wichita
how the [ __ ] you gonna be a gangster in
a state say like nebraska you know
wouldn't be like all hardcore about your
crop just saying that yo [ __ ] was crazy
i'm saying my [ __ ] corn wasn't wrong
my [ __ ] scarecrow was tipping over
and [ __ ] you know what i'm saying son i
just want to be like dude you're white
go to the gap give into it buy some
dockers and come home